Today's bonus episode of 99% Invisible is proudly sponsored by PNC Bank. The world's most remarkable designs are often the ones that are the most overlooked. In fact, a hallmark of great design is that you don't notice it, so it's important to take time to recognize how the boring things spearhead the brilliance all around us. PNC Bank believes in the power of reliability amidst the chaos. While life may offer surprises at every turn, your bank should provide a steady foundation. PNC Bank is committed to being that unwavering partner, a solid foundation of support for your day-to-day life. PNC Bank calls their philosophy, brilliantly boring, which is a mindset I completely relate
今天的《99%隐形》特别节目由PNC银行（PNC Bank）赞助播出。世界上最卓越的设计，往往也是最容易被忽视的。事实上，伟大设计的一个标志就是你不会注意到它，因此，我们花时间去认识那些看似枯燥的事物如何引领我们身边的精彩，是非常重要的。PNC银行坚信在混乱之中，可靠性具有强大的力量。尽管生活随时可能充满惊喜，但你的银行应当为你提供稳固的基础。PNC银行致力于成为那个坚定不移的伙伴，为你日常生活提供坚实的后盾。PNC银行将他们的哲学称为“精彩的无聊”，这种心态我完全感同身
to and in an alternate reality, could have been the name of the show 99% of physical, but we will get to that. Embrace the beauty of dependability with PNC Bank by partnering with a bank that keeps your money boring so your life doesn't have to be. Find out more about how PNC's boring philosophy for your money can help deliver brilliance to your life at pnc.com slash brilliantly boring. PNC Bank, brilliantly boring since 1865. PNC Bank National Association, member FDIC.
受。在另一个平行时空中，这甚至可能成为那个名为“99%的物理”的节目的名字，不过我们一会儿就会聊到这个。与PNC银行携手，拥抱可靠之美。选择一家让你的金钱保持“无聊”，从而让你的生活无需“无聊”的银行。访问 pnc.com 斜杠 brilliantly boring，了解更多关于PNC如何通过其“无聊的理财哲学”为你的生活带来精彩的信息。PNC银行，自1865年起，精彩而无聊。PNC银行国家协会，联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）成员。
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm gonna take you back into the room where it all began. It was 2010, and the San Francisco chapter of the American Institute of Architects approached the radio station where I was working, KALW 91.7, about co-producing a series of short 1-2 minute stories about local architecture. I was working on several different public radio shows as a freelancer, but this idea was immediately compelling to me. My first instinct was to modify the pitch in two key ways.
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我将带你们回到一切开始的那个房间。那是2010年，美国建筑师协会（American Institute of Architects）旧金山分会联系了我当时工作的电台——KALW 91.7，商讨共同制作一系列关于本地建筑的1到2分钟短音频故事。当时我作为自由职业者在几个不同的公共广播节目工作，但这个想法立刻吸引了我。我的第一直觉是从两个关键方面修改这个提案。
First off, I felt that the scope should be all kinds of urban design, not just buildings. And secondly, I knew the stories would need to be a little bit longer than two minutes to be compelling and for the audience to really fall in love with these tiny mundane details. So I advocated for the stories to be four and a half minutes long. That's what I felt was the difference between like a story and love a story. Two and a half minutes. I had no idea how long 99% of visible episodes would eventually become, but at the time I
首先，我觉得其范围应该是各种城市设计，而不仅仅是建筑。其次，我知道这些故事需要比两分钟稍微长一点，才能足够引人入胜，让听众真正爱上这些微小而世俗的细节。所以我力主将故事时长定为四分半钟。我觉得这就是“一个故事”和“一个令人深爱的故事”之间的区别。两分半钟。我当时完全不知道《99%隐形》日后的单集时长最终会变成多少，但在当时，我
was making a tiny radio show about design that would fit into a very crowded radio broadcast clock. So the running time of the episode was of paramount concern. This is all preamble to the room I mentioned a minute ago, the room where the show really began. In the offices of the American Institute of Architects, the executive director Margie O'Drisko gathered for me a group of designers of
制作的是一个要塞进非常拥挤的广播档期中的微型设计广播节目。因此，节目的播出时长是至关重要的问题。这一切都是我刚才提到的那个房间的序言，也就是节目真正诞生的那个房间。在美国建筑师协会的办公室里，执行董事玛吉·奥德里斯科（Margie O'Drisco）为我召集了一群各种各样的
all kinds. There was a prominent architect, a structural engineer, a landscape architect, a product designer, and I asked them what it meant to be a designer. I was looking for insight about how they saw the world. I was looking for leads for stories that I should follow. But most of all, I was looking for a name. I knew I didn't want the word design in the title of the show. I don't know why I was so against that, but I was certain of that. In an effort to brainstorm a name for the show,
设计师。这里有一位杰出的建筑师、一位结构工程师、一位景观设计师、一位产品设计师，我问他们“成为一名设计师”意味着什么。我希望了解他们是如何看待世界的。我在寻找值得我去跟进的故事线索。但最重要的是，我在寻找一个名字。我知道我不希望节目的标题里出现“设计”这个词。我不知道为什么我这么排斥这个词，但我对此非常确信。为了集思广益为节目起个名字，
I asked them if there was a certain set of protocols or processes that they all shared, something that unified them, like a scientific method. And at some point, we came to the conclusion that if they were all doing their jobs right, it was mostly invisible. And then someone pulled out the book, Massive Change by Bruce Mao.
我问他们是否存在某种他们共同拥有的特定协议或流程，某种能将他们统一起来的东西，比如科学方法。在某个时刻，我们得出结论：如果他们的工作都做对了，那它大部分都是隐形的。然后有人掏出了布鲁斯·毛（Bruce Mao）的书《巨大转变》（Massive Change）。
And on the very first page, printed on the in paperpaper itself, is the line, For most of us, design is invisible until it fails. And then, further in the introduction, there's another sentence about the book's mission as laid out by the architect and philosopher Buckminster Fuller, Quote, To comprehend the total integrating significance of the 99% invisible activity which is coalescing to reshape our future. When I heard the phrase 99% invisible I knew I had a name and in a way I knew I
在翻开的第一页，也就是内衬纸本身上，印着这样一句话：“对于我们大多数人来说，设计在失效之前是隐形的。”接着，在导言更靠后的地方，还有另一句关于建筑师兼哲学家巴克敏斯特·富勒（Buckminster Fuller）所阐述的书籍使命的话，引述如下：“去理解99%隐形活动的全部整合意义，这些活动正汇聚并重塑我们的未来。”当我听到“99%隐形”这个词时，我知道我有了名字，在某种程度上，我也知道我
had a premise. I would focus on the invisible parts of design, the undernoticed, not the failures, but the good parts. I would highlight the everyday and the boring and the mundane and talk about how this world is full of genius if you just know how to look for it. What I didn't realize then, but something that I came to realize after working on the show for almost 15 years, is that recognizing all the thought and care that goes into everyday objects is actually really important.
有了前提。我将专注于设计的隐形部分，那些不被注意的细节——不是失败之处，而是好的一面。我将聚焦于日常、无聊和世俗的事物，并探讨只要你知道如何去观察，这个世界是如何充满天才的。当时我没有意识到，但经过近15年对该节目的制作后我逐渐意识到的是，认识到倾注在日常物品中的所有思考和关怀，其实是一件非常重要的事情。
It's more important than a podcast. When your eyes are open to those things, you can feel yourself in the embrace of smart people looking out for you. It's a form of gratitude. People who probably weren't all that heralded, designed and made all the things that make your life possible. It's also important to stop and recognize the everyday so that the everyday continues to thrive. Like anyone who gets annoyed by a road closure
这比一个播客更重要。当你的双眼对这些事物敞开时，你能感受到自己被那些关心你的聪明人所拥抱。这是一种感恩。那些可能并不声名显赫的人，设计并制造了让你的生活成为可能的一切。停下来认识日常事物，对于让日常事物继续繁荣发展同样重要。就像任何会对道路封闭
or a bit of construction that impedes my all-important forward progress, I fail to recognize the world being made better for my benefit right in front of me. Tapping into the spirit of appreciating all the things we make and build for each other is important for getting more of what we need. It's a way to buy into a society that seems like it's ignoring you but actually isn't. Of course, there is bad infrastructure that does harm.
或阻碍了我至关重要的前进步伐的施工感到恼火的人一样，我未能认出这个世界正在我眼前为了我的利益变得更好。挖掘欣赏我们为彼此制造和建造的一切事物的精神，对于获得更多我们所需的东西至关重要。这是一种认同某个看似在忽视你、但实际上并没有忽视你的社会的方式。当然，确实存在会造成伤害的糟糕基础设施。
Elliot Kalin and I are spending a whole year talking about a book that covers that in minute detail. But still, on balance, overlooking the functional and good is too easy to do. So we need reminders. Which brings me to the manhole covers in Osaka, Japan. Now, Japan is the most thoughtfully designed place I've ever been to. The simple act of providing clean public restrooms wherever you might need one feels revolutionary in and of itself compared to the dog-eat-dog world of public facilities in the U.S.
埃利奥特·卡林（Elliot Kalin）和我正花整整一年的时间讨论一本对此进行详尽介绍的书。但即便如此，总的来说，忽视功能性和美好事物实在是太容易了。所以我们需要提醒。这就把我带到了日本大阪的井盖。如今，日本是我去过设计最周到的地方。与美国公共设施那种弱肉强食的世界相比，无论你在哪里需要，都能提供干净的公共洗手间这一简单行为本身就具有革命性。
But even people in Japan need to be reminded of the miracle of reliable infrastructure. What is probably the loveliest manhole cover ever is located in Osaka, Japan, and it shows a blue Osaka castle in relief, wrapped in blue waves and white cherry blossoms. It looks like an ornately etched wood-bock print, even though it is in fact a manhole cover. This beautiful disc was commissioned in the 1980s to commemorate the 100th anniversary of the modern sewer system. It's strikingly artful, but this design approach is not unique to one city or celebration. Colorful illustrations of flowers and animals
但即使在日本，人们也需要被提醒注意可靠基础设施的奇迹。大阪市拥有也许是史上最可爱的人孔盖，上面浮雕着蓝色的大阪城，环绕着蓝色的波浪和白色的樱花。它看起来像是一幅精雕细琢的木刻版画，尽管它实际上是一个井盖。这块美丽的圆形盖板是在20世纪80年代为纪念现代下水道系统建成100周年而订制的。它惊艳且富有艺术感，但这种设计方法并非某个城市或庆祝活动所独有。色彩缤纷的花朵、动物、
and buildings and bridges and boats and mythical heroes and rising phoenixes all adorn stylized manhole covers across Japan. Now, Japanese cities have had various kinds of sewage and drainage infrastructure for over 2,000 years, but subsurface systems with standardized access points are still a relatively modern phenomenon. With standardization came attempts at creativity.
建筑、桥梁、船只、神话英雄以及腾飞的凤凰，点缀着日本各地风格各异的井盖。如今，日本的城市拥有各种污水和排水基础设施已有2000多年的历史，但带有标准化接入点的地下系统相对来说仍然是一个现代现象。随着标准化而来的，是对创意的尝试。
In the mid-1900s, city-specific covers merged, but these were relatively muted and largely colorless. According to a Tokyo-based association of manhole cover makers, the rise of the more expressive covers started in the 1980s, with a ranking construction ministry bureaucrat named Yasutake Kameda. At the time, just over half of Japanese households were connected to municipal sewer systems. Kameda wanted to raise awareness around this vital water infrastructure, in part, to get locals on board for a modern expansion. It's hard to levy the tax money required to improve and expand these kinds of networks
在20世纪中期，城市专属的井盖开始融合，但这些井盖相对低调且基本上没有颜色。根据东京一个井盖制造商协会的数据，更具表现力的井盖的兴起始于20世纪80年代，这要归功于一位名叫龟田泰武（Yasutake Kameda）的高级建设省官僚。当时，只有刚过半数的日本家庭连接到市政下水道系统。龟田希望提高人们对这一至关重要的水利基础设施的认识，部分原因是为了让当地居民支持现代化的扩张。很难征收改善和扩展这些网络所需的税款，
when they are unseen and underappreciated. So Kameda zeroed in on manhole covers as the obvious target for a visibility campaign, a surface expression of an otherwise underground and largely invisible system. So he began encouraging towns and cities to develop and deploy location-specific motifs, and soon municipalities were competing to create the coolest covers around, drawing inspiration from nature, classic folklore, and contemporary culture, including a Hello Kitty manhole cover. The tactic worked, and Manhoru Mania has since inspired photography and rubbings and pens and stickers and even quilting design books based on the art and design of Japanese manhole
因为它们是看不见的，且未受到应有的赞赏。因此，龟田将井盖锁定为宣传可见性的明显目标，作为地下且大体隐形系统在地面上的表现形式。因此，他开始鼓励城镇开发和部署因地制宜的图案，不久之后，各市镇便开始竞相设计周围最酷的井盖，灵感来源于自然、经典民间传说和当代文化，甚至包括Hello Kitty井盖。这一策略奏效了，“井盖狂热”（Manhoru Mania）此后激发了摄影、拓印、钢笔、贴纸甚至是基于日本井盖艺术与设计的拼布设计书籍。
covers. The various designs have some features in common. Complex patterns with lines and curves running in different directions from one another. This cross-hatching offers traction, helping to reduce wheel slippage on wet metal surfaces in rainy or icy conditions. Mini-Manhole covers in Japan have other less visible features designed with safety and quality of life in mind. Tapered designs, which angle inward towards the bottom of the cover, rattle less than conventional round covers with vertical edges when they're driven over,
各种设计有一些共同特征。复杂的图案，线条和曲线彼此朝向不同的方向延伸。这种交叉阴影线提供了牵引力，有助于减少在雨天或结冰条件下湿润金属表面上的车轮打滑。日本的迷你井盖还有其他不太明显、以安全和生活质量为核心的功能。锥形设计——向井盖底部向内倾斜——在被车辆碾压时，比带有垂直边缘的传统圆形井盖产生的晃动更少，
thus reducing noise pollution. For areas that are prone to flooding, including much of Japan, special hinge lids have been engineered so that the cover can flip up but remain attached to the road and then fall back into place when danger passes. This system helps prevent catastrophic lid launches due to high-pressure buildups, which in turn leave behind potentially deadly empty holes in the street. And yes, there have been people sucked into open manholes. While many of these innovations are regional, many basic aspects of manhole cover design
从而减少了噪音污染。对于易受洪水影响的地区（包括日本的大部分地区），人们设计了特殊的铰链盖，这样盖子就可以翻起来但仍与道路保持连接，并在危险过去后落回原位。该系统有助于防止由于高压积聚而导致灾难性的盖子弹射，这反过来又会在街道上留下潜在致命的空洞。是的，确实有人被吸进过打开的井盖里。虽然其中许多创新是区域性的，但井盖设计的许多基本方面
also have some underappreciated genius. Take the round geometry of most covers. A circle is an amazing shape. A circular lid can't fall into the holes that they cap. A square lid or oval lid could be lifted up and turned sideways and chucked into the hole. Once they're lifted out using a pick point or electromagnetic device, heavy round covers can be rolled along the streets like a wheel. So we should all give a round of applause for circles. And while Japan has become well known for the aesthetics of its manhole covers,
也蕴含着一些被低估的天才之处。以大多数井盖的圆形几何形状为例。圆形是一种神奇的形状。圆形的盖子不会掉进它们所盖住的洞里。方形盖子或椭圆形盖子可以被提起来、转个方向然后扔进洞里。一旦用撬点或电磁设备将其提起，沉重的圆形盖子就可以像车轮一样沿着街道滚动。因此，我们都应该为圆形起立鼓掌。虽然日本以其井盖的美学而闻名，
other places have distinctive designs as well, some with regional significance or clever functionality. The triangular manhole covers of Nashville, New Hampshire, for example, point in the direction the subsurface water flows. In Seattle, a series of manhole covers feature embedded city maps. The raised city grid pattern on these also function as a multi-directional anti-slip element. Manhole covers can also be designed to lock into a single right position and function as wayfinding devices, with arrows oriented toward different neighborhoods and other points of interest.
但其他地方也有独特的设计，其中一些具有地方特色或巧妙的功能。例如，新罕布什尔州纳什维尔的三角形井盖指向地下水流动的方向。在西雅图，一系列井盖具有嵌入式城市地图。这些地图上凸起的城市网格图案同时也兼具多方向防滑元素。井盖还可以设计成锁定在单个正确的位置，并用作寻路设备，箭头指向不同的街区和其他兴趣点。
In Berlin, one artist known as D. Rob Dukeren, or the Pirate Printer, rolls paint onto the city's distinctive skyline manhole covers, and then presses down shirts to create casual streetwear. then presses down shirts to create casual streetwear. And I would also argue that the completely standard US metal manhole cover has a real municipal design beauty to it. And even if you can't get excited about that, it's worth getting excited about underground
在柏林，一位名为D. Rob Dukeren或“海盗印刷工”（Pirate Printer）的艺术家将颜料滚到城市独特的城市天际线井盖上，然后压上衬衫以创作出随性的街头服饰。然后压上衬衫以创作出随性的街头服饰。我还要说的是，完全标准的美国金属井盖本身就具有一种真正的市政设计美感。即使你对此无法感到兴奋，但为地下水和污水基础设施感到兴奋也是值得的。
water and sewage infrastructure. Like if you're at Thanksgiving and you're forced to go around the table and say what you're thankful for, indoor plumbing is a perfect perennial example, even if the manhole covers near your home aren't painted like in Osaka. After the break, an overlooked, brilliantly boring foundational structure that was the bridge to the 20th century. After this. In architecture, the most impressive structures often begin with simple, dependable foundations. They embody a timeless balance and solid frameworks that create space for creativity to flourish. PNC Bank wholeheartedly embraces the concept of being brilliantly boring. Even the most impressive buildings depend on essential but boring elements to achieve their brilliance,
就像如果你在感恩节聚餐时被迫轮流说出你感激的事情，室内管道系统就是一个完美的长青例子，即使你家附近的井盖不像大阪那样被涂上了颜色。稍事休息后，我们将探讨一个被忽视的、精彩而无聊的基础结构，它是通往20世纪的桥梁。广告之后见。在建筑领域，最令人印象深刻的结构往往始于简单、可靠的地基。它们体现了永恒的平衡和坚实的框架，为创意的蓬勃发展创造了空间。PNC银行全心全意地拥抱“精彩的无聊”这一理念。即使是最令人印象深刻的建筑，为了实现其辉煌，也依赖于基本但无聊的元素，
regardless of the building's appearance. There are countless behind-the-scenes components that, though seemingly mundane, are crucial to its stability. This philosophy mirrors what PNC Bank stands for. Just as in architecture, where reliability and consistency pave the way for innovation, they provide financial stability to bolster your aspirations. The best designs aren't always the great leaps forward that wow you with their innovation. They are the things that work, use after use, year after year, things that you do not notice because they work so well. Sometimes boring is the best design.
无论建筑的外观如何。有无数幕后的组件，虽然看似平凡，但对于其稳定性至关重要。这一哲学反映了PNC银行的立场。正如在建筑中，可靠性和一致性为创新铺平了道路一样，它们提供财务稳定性以支持你的抱负。最好的设计并不总是那些以创新震撼你的巨大飞跃。它们是那些日复一日、年复一年地发挥作用的事物，因为它们运作得如此之好，以至于你甚至注意不到它们。有时，无聊就是最好的设计。
Embrace the dependability of PNC Bank because much like in architecture and in life, a steadfast foundation empowers you to dream boldly and build with confidence. Find out more about how PNC's boring philosophy for your money can help deliver brilliance to your life. Visit pnc.com slash brilliantly boring to learn more. PNC Bank brilliantly boring since 1865. PNC Bank National Association member FDIC. There's a well-known literary technique called Chekhov's gun, named after the Russian playwright. Basically, if a gun appears in the first act, it better be fired in the following act.
拥抱PNC银行的可靠性，因为就像在建筑和生活中一样，坚定的地基使你能够大胆梦想并满怀信心地建设。了解更多关于PNC如何通过其“无聊的理财哲学”为你的生活带来精彩的信息。访问 pnc.com 斜杠 brilliantly boring 了解详情。PNC银行，自1865年起精彩而无聊。PNC银行国家协会，联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）成员。有一个众所周知的文学技巧叫做“契诃夫之枪”，以这位俄罗斯剧作家命名。基本上，如果一把枪在第一幕中出现，它最好在随后的某一幕中被发射。
There are no unnecessary details. You see a gun, that gun gets used to shoot someone. I have a corollary principle of my own invention, and it relates to movies where there is a scene at a construction site, and it is this. If on the screen you see an ugly shaft of exposed rebar, somebody's getting impaled. There's something about rebar that fascinates me. If nothing else, because there are very few things that invoke a fear of being skewered. My pathological preoccupation with metal reinforcement bars dovetails nicely
这里没有不必要的细节。你看到一把枪，那枪就会用来射击某人。我有一个自己发明的推论原则，它与那些有建筑工地场景的电影有关，即：如果你在银幕上看到一根丑陋的裸露钢筋，就会有人被穿透。某种程度上，钢筋让我着迷。至少原因在于，很少有其他东西能唤起人们对被串起来的恐惧。我对金属钢筋的病态全神贯注，与旧金山的一处结构完美契合，
with a structure in San Francisco that I'm pretty obsessed with. A tiny bridge in Golden Gate Park. This is the Alfred Lake Bridge by Ernest Ransom. This is William Lippman. He teaches architecture at the California College of the Arts and he was the first person to tip me off to the importance of this humble little structure on the very eastern edge of the park. It's sort of the entrance to the park from the hate side, from the kind of hippie slacker hate area right at the edge of the park and sort of leading into the children's playground.
我对那个结构非常痴迷。那是金门公园里的一座小桥。这是欧内斯特·兰森（Ernest Ransom）设计的阿尔弗雷德湖桥（Alfred Lake Bridge）。这是威廉·利普曼（William Lippman）。他在加利福尼亚艺术学院教授建筑学，他是第一个向我透露公园最东端这座不起眼的小结构的重要性的人。这有点像是从海特（Haight）一侧进入公园的入口，从公园边缘那种嬉皮士懒汉海特区直接通往儿童游乐场。
It's not a place that most people really want to linger. It is a spot for drug dealing and various illicit assinations. And that is Robert Corlin, author of Concrete Planet, giving us a lay of the land. We're in the Albert Lake Bridge, one of the earliest surviving reinforced concrete structures in the world. The bridge was constructed in 1889.
这里并不是大多数人真的想逗留的地方。这里是毒品交易和各种非法刺杀的场所。那是《混凝土星球》（Concrete Planet）一书的作者罗伯特·科林（Robert Corlin），在为我们介绍当地的情况。我们在阿尔弗雷德湖桥，这是世界上现存最早的钢筋混凝土结构之一。这座桥建于1889年。
It may be the least appealing sort of monument of architecture or civil engineering. On one side it's cracked where the earth is sort of pressing through. It's covered in mold and lichen. Inside it's this kind of odd surrealistic tunnel of stalactites that really kind of look like some sort of folk art, you know, impression of what the surface of Mars might look like. I think it looks like the inside of a giant colon. It's really unappealing to pass through it. It's not well kept up at all.
它可能是建筑或土木工程中最不具吸引力的纪念碑。在一侧，它开裂了，泥土从缝隙中挤压出来。它长满了霉菌和苔藓。在内部，这是一个奇怪的超现实主义钟乳石隧道，看起来真的有点像某种民间艺术，你知道的，对火星表面可能是什麽样子的印象。我觉得它看起来像是一个巨型结肠内部。穿过它真的很没有吸引力。它根本没有得到很好的维护。
Well, there's nothing remarkable about it. It is an arch. It's actually as much a pedestrian tunnel as a bridge. A pioneering structure in the shape of a dumpy and neglected little bridge. But it's really sad because it is one of the pioneering buildings in the story of reinforced concrete.
好吧，它没有什么了不起的地方。它是一座拱桥。它实际上既是一条行人隧道，也是一座桥。一个以局促且被忽视的小桥形状出现的开创性结构。但这真的很令人悲伤，因为它是钢筋混凝土发展史上具有开创性的建筑物之一。
There are plenty of candidates for the most overlooked, most invisible part of the built world. But reinforced concrete has a good claim to be the most overlooked, most invisible part of the built world, but reinforced concrete has a good claim to be the most invisible of all. Because if it's made right, you never see the steel skeleton underneath all the concrete structures that you work in drive over or walk under. Reinforced concrete is concrete that is strengthened by the addition of initially iron and then later steel to give it tinsel strength. The thing about concrete is it's great in compression, meaning it withstands a lot of pressure in terms of weight,
对于人造世界上被忽视最多、最隐形的部分，有很多候选对象。但钢筋混凝土非常有资格成为人造世界上被忽视最多、最隐形的部分，不过钢筋混凝土非常有资格成为所有事物中最隐形的。因为如果制作得当，你永远不会看到你工作、开车或行走的各种混凝土结构底部的钢铁骨架。钢筋混凝土是通过最初添加铁、后来添加钢来增强抗拉强度的混凝土。混凝土的特点是抗压性能极佳，这意味着它在重量方面能够承受很大的压力，
but it's not very good in tension, meaning when you sort of spanning long distances, it sort of can collapse. So if you see concrete going high in the air or spanning a long distance, there is metal inside of that. And you have this unassuming vanguard of a bridge and its engineer, Ernest Ransom, to thank for it. Ernest Ransom's principal claim to fame
但它的抗拉性能不太好，这意味着当你跨越长距离时，它可能会崩塌。因此，如果你看到混凝土伸向高空或跨越长距离，里面一定有金属。你要感谢这座桥及其工程师欧内斯特·兰森，是他们默默无闻地成为了先锋。欧内斯特·兰森的主要成就在于
is that he's the father of modern reinforced concrete. The experiments done with reinforcing concrete with iron previous to Ernst Ransom, were just one-off experiments. A cottage in England, a house in New York, and a rowboat in France. If you're thinking, did he say a reinforced concrete rowboat? That deserves a follow-up question. Well, you'd be right, but I did not think of it at the time. Ernst Ransom experimented with different forms of iron reinforcement until he hit upon what we now call rebar, which is short for reinforcement bar. And his technology was far beyond any
他是现代钢筋混凝土之父。在欧内斯特·兰森之前，用铁加固混凝土的实验只是一次性的实验。英国的一座乡间别墅、纽约的一所房子和法国的一艘划艇。如果你在想，他说的是一艘钢筋混凝土划艇吗？这值得一个后续问题。好吧，你说得对，但我当时没想到这一点。欧内斯特·兰森试验了不同形式的铁加固，直到他偶然发现了我们现在所说的钢筋（rebar，即reinforcement bar的简称）。他的技术远远超出了当时其他试验钢筋混凝土的人。
of the others who were experimenting with reinforced concrete at the time. A lot of people in Europe and America are playing with putting in bars or metal into concrete at this time. There's many different techniques and everyone's experimenting. What Ransom's sort of major innovation is, is he takes sort of square bar that runs through it and he twists it slightly,
当时欧洲和美洲有很多人在玩弄把钢筋或金属放入混凝土中的技术。有很多不同的技术，每个人都在试验。兰森的重大创新在于，他拿了一根穿过其中的方形钢筋，并将其稍微扭曲，
and that gives it an adhesive quality to the concrete itself. And it sort of stays together much better. Ransom said to come to this idea, he found a twisted rubber band in his pocket one day and thought well that's what I'm gonna do to this iron bar I'm gonna twist it so it just binds to the concrete better. You can see a diagram of this twisted rebar in Ransom's 1884 patent. By the way if you're
这赋予了它与混凝土本身的粘附力。它能更好地粘合在一起。兰森说，为了得出这个想法，有一天他在口袋里发现了一个扭曲的橡皮筋，心想：这就是我要对这根铁棒做的事，我要把它扭曲，这样它就能更好地与混凝土结合。你可以在兰森1884年的专利中看到这种扭曲钢筋的图表。顺便说一句，如果你
anything like me Google patent search is the best way to spend time in front of the computer. I could lose hours jumping from patent to patent. Anyway, this innovation of messing with the bar to help it bond with the surrounding concrete is still used to this day. We put deformations on the reinforcing bar so that the concrete will hold on to it. That scoring is probably why I find rebar
跟我一样，谷歌专利搜索是电脑前消磨时间的最好方式。我可能会在从一个专利跳到另一个专利的过程中浪费好几个小时。无论如何，这种弄乱钢筋以帮助其与周围混凝土结合的创新至今仍在使用。我们在钢筋上制造变形，以便混凝土能够抓住它。这种划痕可能就是我发现钢筋
so ugly and unsettling. That's Bob Risser right there. I'm Bob Risser. I'm president and CEO of the Concrete Reinforcing Steel Institute. He's not the former president, but regardless, I called the CRSI to get the full scope of what reinforced concrete means
如此丑陋和不安的原因。那是鲍勃·里瑟（Bob Risser）。我是鲍勃·里瑟。我是混凝土钢筋研究所（Concrete Reinforcing Steel Institute）的主席兼首席执行官。他不是前主席，但无论如何，我致电CRSI是为了全面了解钢筋混凝土对人造世界的意义。
to the built world. Well, without over-exaggerating the point, I would say that the significance of reinforced concrete is that modern society is not possible without it. Well, as humble as the Albert Lake Bridge is, it is a direct precursor to the Ingalls skyscraper built just 15 years later in Cincinnati, Ohio, the world's first reinforced concrete skyscraper. It also led to bridges, dams, freeways, streets of reinforced concrete.
好吧，如果不夸大其词，我会说钢筋混凝土的意义在于，没有它，现代社会就不可能存在。虽然阿尔弗雷德湖桥很不起眼，但它是15年后在俄亥俄州辛辛那提建造的世界上第一座钢筋混凝土摩天大楼——英格斯摩天大楼（Ingalls skyscraper）的直接前身。它还带来了桥梁、水坝、高速公路、钢筋混凝土街道。
I mean without reinforced concrete, you would only be able to build a series of unconnected asphalt roads. It's a very humble beginning, but it was from here in San Francisco that the reinforced concrete revolution took over the world. That's why we talk about it being the foundation of civilization. It's also a foundation of modern architecture. It made possible forms that were never possible before, like Frank Lloyd Wright's Guggenheim Museum and Jeannie Gang's stunning Aqua Tower in Chicago.
我的意思是，如果没有钢筋混凝土，你将只能建造一系列互不相连的沥青路。这是一个非常卑微的开始，但正是从旧金山的这个地方开始，钢筋混凝土革命席卷了世界。这就是为什么我们谈论它是文明基石的原因。它也是现代建筑的基石。它实现了以前从未可能实现的形态，比如弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）的古根海姆博物馆（Guggenheim Museum）和吉妮·甘g（Jeannie Gang）在芝加哥令人惊叹的水滴大楼（Aqua Tower）。
It's designed to mimic flowing water on the 80-some floors, there are no two floors that are the same. There's no two balconies that are the same. But the problem with reinforced concrete, especially if the rebar isn't covered with enough concrete and is exposed to water and salt, is that the steel inside can rust. And as it rusts, it expands. It expands to almost fourfold its original
它的设计旨在模仿流动的水，在这80多层中，没有哪两层是相同的。没有哪两个阳台是相同的。但钢筋混凝土的问题在于，特别是如果钢筋没有被足够的混凝土覆盖并暴露在水和盐中时，里面的钢铁就会生锈。随着生锈，它会膨胀。它会膨胀到其原始
diameter, destroying the concrete around it while the steel itself is being destroyed by the rust and corrosion. And when that happens, which it will eventually, reinforced concrete doesn't last the thousand years that Ernest Ransom and the early reinforced concrete proponents thought it would. For many many years the design life was about 50 years. The entire interstate system was built under the assumption of a 50-year design. These days, our organization and others
直径的近四倍，破坏周围的混凝土，而钢铁本身则被锈蚀和腐蚀所破坏。当这种情况发生时（而且它最终会发生），钢筋混凝土并不会像欧内斯特·兰森和早期钢筋混凝土倡导者所认为的那样持续一千年。很多很多年里，设计寿命约为50年。整个洲际公路系统就是在假设50年寿命的情况下建造的。如今，我们组织和其他机构
are working with the federal government and state agencies to try to look at 75 and even 100-year designs. Modern reinforced concrete frames encased inside a building superstructure with normal maintenance will last a lot, lot longer. So don't worry, the Burj Khalifa, the tallest tower in the world, and the tallest reinforced concrete structure is not coming down anytime soon. But the clock is ticking for most of the reinforced concrete infrastructure that was put up in
正与联邦政府和州机构合作，试图研究75年甚至100年的设计。在建筑上层建筑内封装的现代钢筋混凝土框架，在正常维护下将持续很长很长时间。所以不用担心，世界上最高的塔楼、最高的钢筋混凝土结构哈利法塔（Burj Khalifa）近期不会倒塌。但对于20世纪中期在美国建造的大多数钢筋混凝土基础设施来说，倒计时已经开始。
the middle of the 20th century in the US. People have to realize that all this that they see around them will eventually have to be, with a few exceptions, will have to be torn down and replaced because we built with steel reinforced concrete. And the cost of that, it will be trillions of dollars, an unbelievable amount of money. Seriously, the stuff that wasn't properly maintained
人们必须意识到，他们周围看到的所有这些最终都将不得不——除少数例外——被拆除和替换，因为我们是用钢筋混凝土建造的。而其代价将是数万亿美元，一笔令人难以置信的金钱。说真的，那些没有得到适当维护的东西
is coming down. And as you can imagine, a lot the stuff that wasn't properly maintained is coming down. And as you can imagine, a lot of our infrastructure was not properly maintained. Particularly with public agencies, where very frankly, the method has been and in some cases still is, you know, a reactionary policy rather than a well thoughtthought-out maintenance routine." Even though concrete has the illusion of permanence, it is not that way at all. You don't just build it and forget it. You have to account for going back and taking care of it like you would anything else. Ernest Ransom left San Francisco soon after he completed the Alfred Lake Bridge.
正在倒塌。正如你可以想象的那样，我们的很多基础设施并没有得到适当维护。特别是对于公共机构，坦白说，其方法过去是、在某些情况下现在仍然是：你知道的，采取反动政策，而不是深思熟虑的维护常规。尽管混凝土给人一种永久的错觉，但它根本不是那样的。你不能只是建造它然后就忘掉它。你必须考虑到回去照顾它，就像你对待其他任何事情一样。欧内斯特·兰森在完成阿尔弗雷德湖桥后不久就离开了旧金山。
In his book, Reinforced Concrete Buildings, published in 1912, which is not the most scintillating of texts, you can detect a tinge of bitterness in Ransom's words as he describes how his twisted rebar was laughed down by the technical society in California. He left for the East, thinking that his revolution of reinforced concrete would have a better chance out there. He left thinking that no one here would fully appreciate his Albert Lake Bridge, that no one here would appreciate this literal bridge to the modern world. And looking at it today, I'm sad to say that he was right. Life can often surprise you with its unpredictability.
在他的著作《钢筋混凝土建筑》（Reinforced Concrete Buildings）中（该书于1912年出版，并非最引人入胜的文本），你可以从兰森的字里行间察觉到一丝苦涩，他描述了加利福尼亚的技术界如何嘲笑他扭曲的钢筋。他前往东方，认为他的钢筋混凝土革命在那里会有更好的机会。他离开时认为这里没有人会充分欣赏他的阿尔弗雷德湖桥，没有人会欣赏这座通往现代世界的字面意义上的桥梁。今天回过头来看，我很悲伤地承认他是对的。生活常常以其不可预测性给你带来惊喜。
While embracing these surprises can be thrilling, there are aspects where stability is key. You want the stability of a 135-year-old bridge that just does its job while still being a hallmark of innovation. Same goes for your bank. Your bank should be the dependable foundation that allows you the freedom to pursue adventure. PNC Bank understands the importance of reliability in unpredictable world. Embrace the dependability of PNC Bank. By keeping your bank boring, you can make your life
虽然拥抱这些惊喜可能令人兴奋，但有些方面稳定性是关键。你希望拥有一座已有135年历史的桥梁的稳定性，它既能完成工作，又仍然是创新的标志。你的银行也是如此。你的银行应该成为可靠的后盾，让你有自由去追求冒险。PNC银行深知在不可预测的世界中可靠性的重要性。拥抱PNC银行的可靠性。通过让你的银行保持无聊，你可以让你的生活
extraordinary. Find out more about how PNC's boring philosophy for your money can help deliver brilliance to your life at pnc.com slash brilliantly boring pnc bank brilliantly boring since 1865 pnc bank national association member fdic 99 invisible was produced this week by me roman Roman Mars, with help from Kurt Kohlstedt. Original music was composed by Swan Real. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potok, Martin Gonzalez, Chris Berube,
非凡。访问 pnc.com 斜杠 brilliantly boring，了解更多关于PNC如何通过其“无聊的理财哲学”为你的生活带来精彩的信息。PNC银行，自1865年起精彩而无聊。PNC银行国家协会，联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）成员。本周的《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）协助。原创音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、妮娜·波托克（Nina Potok）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、克里斯·伯鲁贝（Chris Berube）、
Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Leigh, Lash Madone, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we talk about architecture, we talk about movies, we talk about flags, and we definitely, definitely talk about the Power Broker.
杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·李（Vivienne Leigh）、拉什·马多内（Lash Madone）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stephen Lawrence）创作。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以在我们的Discord服务器上找到我们，我们在那里讨论建筑、电影、旗帜，并且绝对、绝对会讨论《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）。
There's a link to that every past episode and links to PNC Bank, brilliantly boring, at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关每一集过往节目的链接以及PNC银行（精彩的无聊）的链接，都可以在 99pi.org 上找到。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。